The last 24 hours. I've been some of the busiest
in news that I can remember for a very long
time starting [inaudible]
with the release of the whistleblower complaint
that is at the heart of the reason why there
is now an impeachment inquiry against Donald
Trump. Uh, starting in the house of representatives.
This is the whistleblower complaint that made
the original allegations that Donald Trump
was withholding hundreds of millions of dollars
in aid from Ukraine if and until such time
that Ukraine smears Joe Biden for the benefit
of Donald Trump in the 2020 election on the
presumption that Joe Biden is likely to be
a quote, at least according to Trump, uh,
his challenger in the 2020 election, we have
seen suppression of the whistleblower report.
We have seen a quote transcript that is actually
a summary which we will talk about. We have
seen the impeachment inquiry get going. So
all of this stuff stems from the whistleblower
complaint that started at all. It has been
released and it is absolutely devastating
to Donald Trump and completely justifies that
there is now an impeachment inquiry.
Whether the impeachment inquiry is being handled
correctly by Democrats is a different question
which I'll get to later in the show preview.
My thought is Democrats are already blowing
the impeachment inquiry, but we will get to
that. What is in the whistleblower complaint?
Uh, the summary of it, the key points as I
read them are number one, the whistleblower
says Donald Trump is using the office of the
presidency to solicit interference from foreign
powers to help him win 2020 with the involvement
of both Rudy Giuliani, his personal attorney
and attorney general William Barr. The complaint
is based on the reports of more than 60 us
officials speaking to the whistleblower who
as of right this second is still maintaining
anonymity. Uh, and we will see if by the time
you hear this, the whistleblower has not been
named. I fear for the whistleblowers life
if they are no longer anonymous.
The details in the whistleblower report about
the Ukraine call are basically as we already
know them. I mean that's not a surprise. That's
the part that was widely reported earlier
this week. We've been talking about it all
week. It was partially the catalyst for the
impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump and
nothing surprising in the whistleblower complaint
about the content of the call. It coincides
perfectly with what's been reported all week
long. White house officials according to this
report already knew what was going on with
Ukraine before the phone call took place and
they were immediately working the phone call
on various methods to cover up the content
of the call, some of which we have since learned
about some of which involve a different email
servers. Shockingly, I thought it was Hilary
that we had to worry about. The whistleblower
says that about a dozen different people listened
to the phone call in question on July 25th
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president.
The records of the call were immediately quote
locked down according to the whistleblower,
including the actual transcript which exists
to this report. This is important to understand.
Donald Trump ultimately released a summary
of the call, not a transcript of the call,
which we will get to the actual transcript
does exist. And this of course suggests that
they knew all along the importance of covering
up the actual full records of what was said
during the phone call. White house lawyers
reportedly went to white house officials and
said, remove the electronic transcript and
put it onto a different computer system that
allegedly took place. And we are going to
talk about that more in detail as well. The
whistleblower complaint also says that Rudy
Giuliani has been traveling all over the world
to meet with different Ukrainians, including
for example, going to Spain to meet with advisor
to the Ukrainian president, Andre, your Mac
or your neck.
It's hard to actually tell. Uh, the M N looks
a little hard to tell what it is when you
look at the PDF of the complaint. Uh, so what
have we learned? Additionally from the whistleblower
complaint, we've learned about the moving
of the electronic records to different servers,
which I'll get into detail next. We've learned
that William bar needs to be completely separated
from every proceeding that is even remotely
related to this because he is named as one
of the players in this attempt in 2020 interference
involving Ukraine. He has to recuse himself
and it is stunning that yet another of Donald
Trump's attorney generals should recuse themselves
from one of the most important stories involving
the actions of the president. And unfortunately,
William Barr is involved in a lot of this
stuff because he heads up the justice department,
so he should immediately recuse himself, will
he?
I have no idea. And of course, the obvious
conclusion from reading the whistleblower
complaint is that even if even 15% of the
report is accurate, the impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump is 110% warranted. So
now let's get into detail about the separate
computer system to which the whistle blower
alleges records of the July 25 phone call
between Trump and the Ukrainian president
were moved.